feel your country as well yeah what's
worse they sponsor these [ __ ] are too
busy trying to look good in Parliament
and argue with each other to get
anything actually done you know like
what are the big issues in Australia I
don't know because I don't tuned into it
anymore
well you guys have crazy immigration
laws you don't let anybody go over there
it's like people who think that the
United States is rough with this whole
wall thing oh yeah Australia takes that
to a whole new level this ship you go to
an island yeah right Christmas all it's
a [ __ ] nice Island though is it yeah
well think about what you guys are I
mean you guys replace the the British
yeah hide all their prisoners to a
better place
exactly I did all the security fencing
around some of the detention centres so
you've pretty much you're on that island
you know and then you get shipped to
like the hottest most [ __ ] arid part
of Australia like it's deaf and I did
the fencing around there and then I
believe they're there for so long and
then they can you know they ever get
shipped back home or they can go out to
the broader community in Australia which
they get treated very well obviously so
is it just an assessment place like were
they trying to find out criminal yeah
yeah violent yeah I think that's that's
the important thing
you know that's why you can't just have
open borders you know some terrorist
comes in right
some guy thinks [ __ ] rapes fine some
guy that thinks you know crazy shits
fine you know assess those people and we
can send them off all yeah but if you
did that in the most arid part of
America people would be so angry because
people start dying no people are angry
in Australia as well I think and stuff
like that what are you supposed to do
it's a tech you know it's a very it's a
hard situation yeah it's not something
that's just like no just let him through
no [ __ ] no and it's not like just don't
let him through ro knows that middle
ground again you know let's assess them
let's work it out because I always think
what if I was in their shoes you know I
got Kim and the kids or whatever and now
we're in a country that's war [ __ ]
stricken I'd be trying to get the [ __ ]
out of there too
you know no matter what it took yeah you
know well not no matter what it took but
but you know of course yeah I mean I
always say that about people that are
talking about people sneaking over this
country I mean like this country is made
of immigrants yeah it's an immigrant
country yeah what do you expect when you
go oh good Oh [ __ ] country's
immigrants yeah I mean that is that's
like people in LA saying they don't want
anybody moving to LA yeah [ __ ] where
you from look at this dryer like if
you're [ __ ] why you're an import
right and by the way if you are one of
the original people came here I mean one
of the original European settlers you're
probably a [ __ ] slave on yeah yeah
your grandparents were slave owners like
if you if you didn't come over here as a
recent immigrant like I'm third
generation my grandparents came over
here from Europe if they didn't then if
they were here for 10-15 generations
they're probably [ __ ] so I actually I
never feel a real good connect with
anywhere I go including my home
Australia because I'm not indigenous you
know it's like weird and so I've always
looked at cuz you know I don't worry
about [ __ ] flags or borders or
anything like that I've just always
looked at the world the world home well
specially so much time with the Indians
people in Austria yeah yeah because of
work and not you know like a no
disrespect to any flag I love the flag
and I love what they stand for but it's
only someone's design a board is only
something that someone's put on the map
yeah you know it's it's like a real
weird thing like that
it is a weird thing but also you want to
protect people from people that come
from oh it's unless the whole world was
the same unless everybody whole world
was on the same level you know we're not
gonna do this we're not gonna do that
this is illegal this is fine let's the
whole world was like that then borders
would be easy to cross well that's
actually what America's we've been
talking about this a lot that America is
essentially like Europe but everybody
speaks the same language but you can go
to any country mmm like New Mexico is
[ __ ] way different than Miami yeah
right Miami is way different than la la
is way different than Seattle those are
all almost like completely different
place hardly but they're all you could
go to him I mean ideally that's what
we're it would be it would be you could
travel it anywhere where the opportunity
was we thought you can get a good job
and you want to better yourself your
family you'd have an opportunity yeah
the fact that currency and life values
are different for starters yeah he's you
why that kind of happened yeah you know
to be nice well be nice it would be nice
if one day the whole world rises up and
you know when you look at the Western
world whether it's Europe or the United
States and places where things are going
really well or Asia it would be nice if
the whole planet was like there if there
was no third world if everything was
fantastic if everything was just
basically just like we're talking about
here hey you can live in Phoenix or you
can live in Billings Montana or you
could live in Massachusetts whoever the
[ __ ] you want that's what we have here
we have a real unique thing in this
country and that's why people want to
come in yeah it's [ __ ] good pretty
dope I hear a lot of because you always
hear the negative things and I hear a
lot of people dragging on America in
their own country and stuff like that
you know this is [ __ ] these [ __ ]
America is brilliant Australia is
brilliant these countries are all so
[ __ ] lucky to be here yeah you know
because you look at other parts of the
world and you're like [ __ ] yeah they
can't feed their baby yeah do you know
the mean like yeah